this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by skillshare and raycon more on
that later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
you can follow me on social media ryan
sickler brian sickler.com
please subscribe to the youtube i see
how many of you are watching
uh the community has grown like like i
said i don't know when these episodes
will air but within a year we've built
it to like a hundred thousand and i
don't know what
other people are out there doing that
might not be [ __ ] i really don't know
but i [ __ ] think it's pretty good so
thank you for your support
i love to see the community going the
guests the stories
are just fantastic uh and the patreon if
you want another episode a week go
subscribe to the patreon it's five bucks
a month if you sign up for a year you
get a month free
uh and again i don't know when this is
going to air because we're recording
ahead because ash is moving to austin
like everybody
else uh beginning may 1st you're going
to get the honeydew
for free excuse me ad free
a day early all right ad free a day
early at no additional
i guess it is free i'm not charging
until maybe 2022. we'll see about that
uh but anyway subscribe and if you or
someone you know has that story that's
got to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
um and again i know that's a lot of
money for some people right now
especially after what we're all going
through and uh if you have it hey
i'd love to have you i mean you do not
need to be a patreon member
to submit your story all right uh you
guys know i record here at the santa
monica music center we're working with
outreach through the arts right now
teaching the kids how to podcast
uh they got a great show we're still
working on here now
and i'm very excited to bring that to
you as i am very excited to bring this
guest to you today all right you guys
know we do here we highlight the low
lights these are the stories behind the
storytellers ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the honeydew for the
first time kristoff and y'all welcome to
the honeydew
my man thank you man i'm i'm really
looking forward to some conversation
i love that you're here i appreciate you
reaching out
um before we begin anything please plug
promote
everything you have do it up everything
this is christopher
whatever you want you know i i'm not big
at plugging things if you follow the
stories and you want to
you want to check stuff out it's pretty
easy just go to my my personal website
chris duffin that's like
muffin but with a d all right really
simple
or christopherduffin.com yeah if you
you're listening to this on some device
you type that thing in
the little google window or whatever uh
my name will pop
up if you get on social media you type
in chris duffin you don't need to
remember any avatar or whatever the
script things are
i'll pop up i got the little blue check
thing there there next to me so
follow along i do stuff around um
well improving mostly in the physical
realm but we're going to talk mental
stuff today because i do a lot on that
yeah but everything that i do is i sell
the best biomechanically
sound barbells and products in the world
uh
at kabuki strength
k-a-b-u-i-k-k-a-b-u-k-i
strength com coaching and education we
work with
90 of professional sports teams in north
america is that right
uh we're working with we work with the
ravens uh
i don't know all the teams right now i'm
terrible uh orioles
memorial yeah do you yep you should just
say yeah even if you don't make me feel
so
uh well major league baseball they need
some [ __ ]
we work with help them out there's 30
teams we work with 29 of them for
example so when i say when i say 90
i mean like it's you know any major
college you listen to
uh big uh marvel studios actors for the
current movie all the actors for black
adam and
you know dwayne johnson uses our stuff
uh yeah i mean your starting line for
the lakers
for everyone so and i love the show
they're the best so i love the whiskey
and the deadlifts
we could talk about that yeah uh and
barefoot athletics
uh so best and minimalist shoe
uh as far as improving foot mechanics
around that's barely b-e-a-r
and you'll understand why the reference
to
bears for barefoot once we get into
these stories
i want to check those out and then yeah
if you lift weights and use supplements
build fast formula that's what i that's
my
mind as well so i'm kind of all over the
place yeah
everything that i do and believe in i
bring to life all right i love that dude
i love that and
and i love what you said too we're here
to talk about mental health today with
you
specifically because you emailed your
list
i ask people to put their trauma in a
list and it just hits different when you
list your trauma if you've never
done it before where you write it out
and you're like oh my god
oh my god i've been through some [ __ ]
you know but you have
quite a story so let me ask you there is
a best-selling book
yeah i was going to say you got the
autobiography the eagle and the dragon i
actually read the audio version too so
it's unavailable on
amazon barnes and noble audible all that
sort of stuff link through my website as
well and if you
you can get a free audio download
through my through my website oh that's
great that's really cool
all right so you uh where are you
originally from
that's a tough one to pin down all over
the wilderness of northern california
and eastern oregon okay so you're a
wilderness uh
family wilderness wilderness yes yes
like you said you start you mentioned
something at six so just take me there
like do you have brothers and sisters i
got
three sisters and a brother and you guys
were all out in the wilderness
yes with both parents yes
tell me about that well just
six years old were
there's a meadow a little stream running
through it in the mountains no roads
into this
and next to that little stream that's
our campsite we've got
beams lashed up into the trees and we
say campsite what are you living in tent
the beams lashed into the trees there
are beddings up there
because there's rattlesnakes like tree
fort we're talking yes
tree forts well you lived in a tree yes
i lived in a tree fort
usually it was tents uh or
you know a condemned home or something
of that nature
but at this time it was tree forts this
is northern california
it's up in the trinity wilderness uh
just off of uh humboldt county i've been
up there yeah
in the 80s there's pretty wild territory
people running around with machine guns
and things like that out there because
uh
the weed growing yeah i've seen murder
mountain yeah yeah
so that's where we lived because that's
what my parents did
uh in a manner trying to make money okay
but
also yes but uh it was bigger just
more of not wanting to be part of
society so six years old i'm sitting
there and i've got
a live rattle snake in my hand
right and it's all of a sudden
it's i'm holding its head you know it
pinched right behind the jaws you know
between how big
it was wrapped all the way down around
my forearm which is like it's
silky smooth like it's just this
coldness you know yeah i've had one on
my neck
not a rattlesnake but a black snake [ __ ]
that and
wait you're you're sick and you're
squeezing it where the mouth is
because you have to keep the mouth open
and controlled
and it's sitting there in order to do
what what is the point of this
to overcome fear for most people right i
mean i'm not [ __ ] kidding you
who's teaching you this lesson this is
your dad or your mom
my stepfather oh your stepfather okay
okay well that sounds like some stuff
popping
and it's just one so i can say it's
sitting there it's got you know those
snake eyes like a real thing you know
staring you in the eye and it's it's
sitting there hissing and you know
like is that [ __ ] going on your arm
not when it's like that so that's when
they're coiled in the bush ready to
strike
and so but that's what i'm learning how
to manage
because if i'm out walking around and
doing this stuff by my you know walking
around
the home right which is the wilderness
and there's rattlesnake dance around
the kitchen it's right over here right
by the redwood right there in the
kitchen
okay we're gonna all right my mom's
pregnant at the time with my
with my second sister and there's a time
that
rattlesnake was sitting there poised and
ready to strike behind her in a bush
while we're sitting come on
i'm not joking you and my stepfather's
having to like warn her but like make
sure he's not
scared you know like striking the snake
at the you know or
at the same time i got anxiety here and
i can't i don't like okay i gotta go so
anyway
it it's yeah to be able to manage those
because they're going to be around and
so
so you went that you picked it up no
what you do is you have a you always
walk with a stick
okay with a y in the end so it's cut and
by why i mean like about the length of
your finger
veed at the end and so what you do is
you have to once they're
they're coiled um you got to understand
that they can strike
about two times as far as what they look
like i've learned that
yeah so you tease it it'll come out and
strike
and then you catch that right over the
head right behind the head right
so you know you you got them and then
then you're while you're holding it down
then you're holding it down you reach
down you grab it right and then that y
has got to be small enough to pin it
against the ground
yeah man there's a lot of mistakes you
can make here you pick
and then you can grab it safely right
and then
you have to know where to cut the head
off too because we're going to eat it
right we're going to skin it because
we're going to sell the we don't have
any money
said they were attempting to grow weed
and doing other stuff but we
we had no money like we had nothing
otherwise we'd probably have a home to
live in and they would drive to them
right right yeah yeah so so you're gonna
sell the
the skin sell the skin you're gonna eat
the meat i've had rattlesnakes but you
to cut it you know right behind you you
got to know where the venom sacks are
which are in the neck behind the head
and
but it's it was a lesson learned how to
how to actually be safe
but at the same time you know mentally
by doing the most dangerous [ __ ] you can
for the most part well it's the
environment i lived in now here's a
here's
here's a funny story about my mom being
pregnant okay my mom is a tough cookie
i've learned so much from her okay only
white people would do this [ __ ] black
people
if there's ghosts or snakes they're
[ __ ] like we're moving man
so my mom goes in though she's going
into labor
and so she has to hike out to the dirt
road
and wait for somebody to drive along the
first person to come along for some
reason was a dump truck
wait she has to hitchhike because this
is what year
1982
and how many kids already are there uh
one three
so dad's now back with the three kids at
home
and mom has to work i'm probably i'm
probably watching
so that's i grew up watching by taking
care of the family but you're six
yeah but i hear you but you're six well
well you're over there handling
rattlesnakes so you know uh you're
already 14. i had no childhood
he's jumped a lot of years that day so
mom walks the road to thumb it to get
taken in town to a hospital yes and how
far is that
that's so long ago i don't remember but
and you're letting your wife
get into the first [ __ ] car that
could be a lunatic
yeah yeah but a dump truck rolls back
jump back
and he picks her up he picks her up
except you guys see this
no this is her it's probably like at
least a mile that you know uh away
right so i can't even right
so so uh apparently i don't know why
there was two people in a truck
they there wasn't room for her so she
has to climb in the bed of the dump
truck
get the [ __ ] out of here they drive they
drive
they drive to town which is probably you
know 45 minutes an hour down into
like society and they drive up to the
hospital
and my mom climbs out of the bed of the
dump truck goes in the hospital and
delivers i've been like
stop me just pull it dump me i'll slide
it out
so so they delivered your mom to the
hospital
the dump truck yeah in the back of a
dump truck yes
that's insane your mom is a soldier bro
oh
no later you'll realize just how much of
a tough cookie she is
so uh and when i tell the stories about
my upbringing my people like oh your
your family must be
you know not that bright or you know
mountain folk or
white trash or all this sort of stuff
and we look the part i mean we go into
town and
clothes are dirty you know high water
pants knees
sticking through you know not as a
fashion statement
um i went to school like ash
[Music]
this is a question i want to ask you
about your mom and your dad's
relationship for a minute
are they on the same page or are they
fighting like
i feel like if you're gonna make a
wilderness family work
you better be on the same [ __ ] page
my mom was in control
so she always had men that were going to
do what she
wanted and i don't know how she did that
but she's i think
she didn't think that she did that okay
i think so
uh she was she was uh she was she was
going to school to be a chemical
engineer had a scholarship was top of
her classes
she said you know before she had her
first kid yeah before me i was the first
oh you're first yeah uh and actually she
was still going to school with me and
then
she she had some we're not going to get
into her life but she had some really
rough trauma
in her childhood some really bad [ __ ]
happened and
authority not her deal
and she basically decided that she did
not want to live
as part of society and so she still
lives in kind of the environment that
we're talking about yeah
oh wow okay so what does she live in
though for real she's not been or
she's got a mobile home mobile uh in a
town of about a hundred people in a
county i think there's 800 people total
in the county no [ __ ] out in the desert
and she is a minor she's got uh she does
uh rocks and things like that and
doesn't
doesn't like being around people yeah
and
lives she's lived her life 100 on her
terms
and so this was the early of trying to
figure out how to make a living
um you know in being you know not a
living but just
you know the lifestyle the being outside
of
what we're used to and uh she did that
and in essence when we get to it i've
kind of ended up doing the same thing
but within society but
i'm gonna say you're not that person
so uh i forgot where i was going you're
back to
uh your rattle snakes your mom's dump
truck she has a baby
she comes back oh yeah so i was just
saying this is yeah it's child number it
was a worse
it was a choice yeah yes it's a choice
it was your parents i was asking if
they're on the same page but you're like
your mom's running the show my mom was
on the show he was along for the ride
and uh yeah so that stepped on that dump
truck your mom wrote
rom rolled solo on that right yeah so
but so what happens then where do you
how long are you there before and are
you being
i mean i don't even want to use the term
home school you don't really have a
[ __ ] home are you being tree fort
school
like how are you being
usually summertime we were 100 in the
mountains got it and then that's where i
said it may be a condemned home it may
be a home without running water or
electricity or something like that
or sometimes it was um through the
winter
or through the school year we would go
in closer to town
and i would be enrolled in school and my
kid sisters
were enrolled in school later you know
and so that's where
you know kind of rough upbringing for me
just like i did not
relate to people very well i wanted to
ask you like did it ever
because this is this is what's crazy
about trauma and in our lives like
the weirdness and all that [ __ ] when
you're it's normal to you
it's what you know you don't know a
[ __ ] thing but what happens when you
get to school
do you have do you spend the night at
friends homes uh do they ever ask to
come to yours like
what is that sort of like definitely
didn't have friends at my place
and actually i've got a really really
sad story
uh about that that was really early on
that kind of shut a lot of that down for
me
um this was in a very remote town in uh
in
called hyunpalm out in northern
california again out on the trinity
like you get to an hour you get to a
town of 5000 people and then another
hour you get to this little town
that's got you know a run one room
schoolhouse and a little general store
and i had a friend and this was uh first
grade
and i started staying the night at this
house because it was nice
that's awesome that's gonna be easy yeah
so i ended up staying the night every
night at this house for like a week
right and i asked my parents like
hey i want to spend the night at his
house again they're like no you you
can't because
you're you know imposing on them you're
we don't you know my parents never
wanted to ask for charity or ask for
help or do like
we didn't they were very we're on our
own very proud
and we got in a fight like i threw a
tantrum it was when your fight was not
really
uh the correct term when you're in first
grade right
and i remember that i was throwing a
tantrum i went home i was and you know
cried in my room i was all upset
and that next morning i found out
um the house
burnt down and the entire family
died in it no i didn't i didn't speak
for a year
are you real yeah from like what age six
to seven somewhere in there you didn't
speak for a year
yeah what oh man you got so many stories
all right let's talk about that for a
moment how do you come out of that
it's tough i don't even i don't really i
don't really remember
so well here's the thing though at the
end of the year we're up in the
mountains again
and there's there's been a couple
interactions with some police officers
so they come out they're based way far
away and
there's this uh this police officer and
he
people are known for like kind of
disappearing around the guy right
and and they would be out in these
remote communities and
yeah the people like their stories
running like hey what happened to
so-and-so
and so he shows up at our at our where
we're staying this uh
uh use there used to be a mill and there
were some homes for people that
worked the mill and they were really
torn down and that's where we lived
okay right it was this little string of
uh i don't know what you call but
run down shacks and and he comes up to
uh
to the door and knocks on the door and
mom's open it and there's a pile of weed
on the table and he's like i'm
i'm arresting you taking you in and she
knows the stories
and she says chris you you gotta run and
find
pat my my stepfather and so so i and i
take off
and i find him you know partying you
know
you know down the road a half mile away
or so ago and i'm like hey you need to
come back and
mom says bring people so they come back
and they watch and everybody's one cop
just there's two cops two okay
and they just observe because that's all
she wanted to know was make sure people
knew that she was being taken into
custody
and so for somebody they got pissed
about that so they end up not even just
taking her to the jail in that county
they went to the county over it was even
further away because they knew it would
be hard for us to get
get to her because vehicles and things
like that is a challenge
you got to find somebody to get a car so
you can go and go there
and it's hours away you know through oh
it's hours
yeah and we're talking we're out in the
trinity alps it's like the
this mountain range like everywhere you
go is these big windy roads like
it's remote and that plays really
important in this story
so that was during the school year
and then that summer we're up in the
mountains
and we're camped out i'm i'm
[Music]
you know it was like in the morning uh
she's still in jail at this time no
she's out so she
it you know took a few days right got
her out
and we're up there so it's mom and pat
are still around
you know it's in the morning and we see
we're set up our camp set up
so we can see the big win the road
coming up the mountain from
miles in advance when we see a bunch of
police cars coming up
and mom's like chris you've got to watch
the kids she takes off
pat takes off right so she's out killing
her local grow site which is just their
look
their actual you know their supply and i
don't know what pat's doing because the
commercial grow sites are long ways away
and uh police show up and they take uh
olives kids into custody
so i just want to understand there's
four children just sitting there when
the cops show up you being the five at
this point
five and you being the oldest and it's
just like where are your parents you're
like man just us right here hanging out
yeah
yeah where did you i got to ask where
did you guys go to the bathroom
just outside is that all you did yeah i
mean you didn't dig
outside yeah you'd give a holy barrett
you know where'd you shower
uh so the the best way to shower is you
take gallon jugs to the stream
and you fill them up and then you go out
and you find a sunny spot on a rock and
you set them out there and i did this
all the way up through high school
you set them out on a rock during the
summer and they warm up and in the end
of the day
you dump them over your head i know i
love you dude
oh that that's it through high school
that's what i'm saying i understand like
that's like high school when we were in
oregon
and it was it was uh we we we're
we definitely didn't cam i mean we'd
live in trailers through the winter we
had a 16-foot trailer
family that size in a 16-foot trailer uh
which i don't know
that's the size of this room yeah it's
nothing there's nowhere to live
and you sit there and that's it and then
you roll it out and then you sleep that
you don't even move
so i would be wandering around but
anyway um uh you would heat the water on
the
wood stove and step out the back door in
the snow
and dump it over your head to bathe like
that's this is my
this is the way i live it's amazing i'm
sorry i i i i took you down off on a
tangent but
this story show up please show up this
is a really critical story your mom's
cutting the the personal stash we don't
know where the [ __ ] pat is and they take
the phone
my sisters my brother they're all just
what are they what's the young car
uh she's nine months months you got an
infant yeah okay
and sorry i might get emotional in this
part of the story just
wake up i'm getting emotional and uh
so yeah it was a little weird experience
i still reflect on it today because
we're in the car
and my sisters are bawling in the back
and i'm just sitting in the front with
no emotion whatsoever and i'm like
inwardly going what's wrong with me
why am i why am i you know when i'm just
a kid
like i'm second grade uh yeah i think i
was second grade at the time
and i'm like why am i not responding to
this situation i'm sitting here asking
the police officer about his
is my inner dialogue about his uh radio
stuff and other things in the car
because it was fascinating to me
because i hadn't seen anything like that
you know
yeah and but we end up getting taken and
putting in foster care my mom gets they
they catch my mom they throw her in jail
oh
[ __ ] and
my mom is in jail for you know
a few months i don't remember what the
charges exactly were
and she has a dream and she's like
there's something funny about this cop
who's now the sheriff
what people disappear around him
and the way the child protective
services and like you know the things
that she's seen
she's like something's click and she's
like
this is this is not good and she
contacted the d.a
and told them the story and he is like i
believe you
and they investigated so hold on so this
now sheriff has a past history of people
disappearing around him
yeah and you said you mentioned the
child protective services the
they're somehow remember this well
that's where they take us and then they
right and then this happens with other
people because they
this happened you know they're helping
these they're basically they don't wanna
they're taking these children these
people in the remote areas that nobody
cares about because they're trash
right right who's going to these bigger
cities far away
and put them in these areas and are all
of you children
you and your siblings are you guys all
together in this one place they've
separated they separated
how many everyone in a different place
my
sisters were all together with the same
person
okay because it was a human trafficking
ring
ugh the cops are they're on this [ __ ]
yes how's your mom [ __ ] put that
together i don't know
but this is real deal this was in
national news
tell me please tell me everything they
caught they caught the end of the man
that had my sisters
as he was boarding a plane to leave the
country he was trying to take him out
sorry
i'm getting a little no they they he was
trying to escape once they
he was running but they were prepping
to sell them so what tell me
to what do you guys know where they i
don't know
so the sheriff went to prison he did and
a lot a number of the police officers
and uh this person his name was jamie
bodison i do remember that my memory
around these times are really tough
titles are running that was the guy that
had my sister sisters okay
so your sisters were placed with this
man yeah
which already is [ __ ] up well it was a
family sure yeah but
but yeah and they
just we're just gonna leave the story
here and move on okay but
um yeah uh
but you so were you and your brother
were together then my brother
actually ended up he had a different
father and uh he ended up
uh being uh taken by them and that's a
really
that's a really rough story too um
they will touch on it later sure so uh
he's up in the mountains right now
just out of prison uh i think he's got a
generator
get some water from a stream and he's
still there he's still there he's still
doing it in the same area
still doing the same thing just living
um
he's got a lot of [ __ ] to deal with and
i'm trying to help him but there's only
so much you can do for someone
so so they do they
then let your mom out of jail yes okay
my mom gets out of jail
uh and she's still they're still working
so she can't take us yet because they're
like well you guys don't even have a
home you don't have like there's still
issues right
so my grandparents from idaho drive down
rushed down
got pictures of us picking us up in the
courthouse after all this
and they take us back there and so we
spend the summer with grandparents
uh before uh parents make a home in
mom's parents uh yes okay um
well her mother um and
uh so they move up to oregon
her and uh pat my stepfather my sister's
father
and set uh set up a home hey we're gonna
we're gonna get out of the drug trade
can't can't ever have this opportunity
of losing the kids again
and so they were able to uh get us back
and then uh
we spent about a year being quasi-normal
there before
um you know mom's just like this he'd
need to get back to being away from
people and so they
moved into the mountains again uh and
picked up uh
kind of mining logging things like that
living in tents and
it's where the 16-foot trailer came in
uh and uh
there's seven of you in there well not
my brother though okay that's right
yeah so it was down to six of you six of
us in a 16-foot trailer
that's right so i i just walk around the
i
you know the you'd have to leave to get
anything i did but it's cold
it's it's oregon in winter like there's
a
you know what we're right off the road
there's a stream running by but it's
frozen over so i'd like ice skate with
my shoes up and down the stream into the
mountains and back and go hiking
i'd hike all over the mountains by
myself and and that's uh
that's what i did and then during the
summer i'd help with uh either
logging or mining so a lot of a lot of
time just work like
it's my whole life like a very physical
uh type stuff and then so can i ask you
because we've talked about pat which
you've said as your stepfather
do what do you did you have a
relationship with your biological father
did you
i did i did so uh my biological father
was uh
uh he oh gosh
um he didn't have a job because he was a
major uh bipolar depressive runs in the
family so his mother shot her
shot her head off with a shotgun uh his
brother jumped out of a building here in
l.a
there it goes all the way back so i
don't have a family on that side he
he attempted suicide i think about seven
times i watched one of them
what do you mean uh he covered poured
himself with gasoline
and stood there with a lighter
threatening to kill himself
i'm not laughing at that i have just
can't believe the [ __ ] you were telling
me
not that i'm done don't believe you're
lying i am just in disbelief like
he was in front of you and covered
himself yeah poor guess and then
and then threatened to do it or didn't
try to do it yeah and then he ended up
uh he he told me to call someone which
was his uh aaa
person and they came and got him and i
was i didn't
wait until the last second i didn't tell
my mom because i knew i wouldn't be
allowed to see him anymore so
i went and stayed with some of his
friends for the rest of the you know the
week or two weeks during the summer that
i go see him
with some family i didn't know who it
was but i couldn't like let that happen
but yeah he was a he was an interesting
man he was he spent like three years in
tibet up in the
uh monasteries very spiritual got me
into
uh meditation at an early age we all see
these spiritual
you know people and and uh i
i learned a lot from him but he just
wasn't capable
that's why he was okay with my mom you
know
taking me he knew he couldn't manage
being a father and raising me okay
and um also my mom said that she'd
freaking kill him i read it in a letter
uh
yeah when he after he passed i was
reading through my stuff i'm like
that's my [ __ ] mom right there and
she's she's hard as [ __ ]
she's like this is the way it is i love
you i've always loved you
don't [ __ ] try to this is what she
wrote him from prison
or from jail when i was so that's why i
he didn't come and take me
because she's like you're not taking my
son you know what'll happen
and uh so from prison she had that power
yeah
yeah that's fine so uh you said your dad
passed
he passed yeah so uh we had an
interesting
he dealt with alcohol his whole life i
mean i remember i'd i just
jump on a bus and go down and see him
figure out my way to route like i'm
freaking i can't believe i'd do this
like
you know fourth fifth grade i would be
like hey mom i'm gonna go see my dad for
the summer she's like you talk to him
right and i'm like oh yeah you know what
and i'm going i sent him a letter like a
month ago saying i was gonna come see
him she's like okay
uh and i'd get a 14 a greyhound bus
ticket down to uh
san francisco and i'd figure out the bus
route from san francisco up to santa
rosa and show up at his place like
what the [ __ ] am i doing like i reflect
back i'm like but there was one time
i showed up in san francisco and i
couldn't remember the route to get to
his house so i tried calling him
and the phone kept buzzing so i'm stuck
in san francisco greyhound station for
like a day
trying to talk to the operators because
it's going let break the call with my
dad and they're like we can't do that
and i'm like
hey come on i'm like a 12 year old kid
here in san francisco i'm freaking out
like
and so like we'll break the line turns
out he he was drunk and
melted the phone line together uh and uh
he melted it yeah so it ran it red is
busy
and uh but they could get through and so
he like
you know he's all worried so he paid for
a taxi from san francisco to santa rosa
for me which was hundreds of dollars at
the time that was a lot of money back
then hell yeah there's another time i
show up and i'm like
he's like i gotta walk down to uh get
you and i can see him coming from long
ways away and he's got
piss lines upon piss lines on his
sweater and his shirt because he'd been
in bed for two weeks and hadn't got out
no way and he just been pissing himself
because
that required getting up and
yeah so it was it was an interesting
relationship
but uh he passed and
it was it was a really crazy experience
um were you any chance you were there
did you get to see him before he passed
or was it sudden or what
it was uh i was sitting
in oregon by this time i was working as
a professional
and it was friday it was
friday afternoon the last day before
christmas shut down for the
manufacturing facility and i'm in the
gym i'm in the gym locker room
just post workout sitting on the bench
getting ready to put my clothes on and
figure out you know
hanging out with friends and stuff like
that over the next couple weeks and what
i was gonna do
phone rings on the bench and it's uh
sheriff he's like hey this is the
sheriff for uh medicine
county um you know uh
your father passed away it's been a
couple weeks uh
ago but we've had trouble finding you
and you're the only family member we
need you to come down here
and take care of his face family member
yes oh
and so anyway i go down
i take care of everything get him
cremated and
uh he's living in a housing complex uh
for people and i just put all this stuff
out in the middle so that people could
take all his books that so he was
he my whole family's avid readers that's
all we ever do
do was read my mom my stepfather
everything we didn't have tv we didn't
have radio yeah
the library was i mean we would just get
stacks of books we're so like that's
my family is like uh we may have been a
white trash mountain folk but we were
first like that yeah that was what we
did
yeah and uh let's take a quick break and
tell you about our first sponsor
skillshare skillshare
is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning
with so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth so i've told you before
about skillshare i love doing their
classes right now
i've been doing kids kitchen cooking
from scratch
with kids under five that's the class
i've been working with stella in the
kitchen
trying to get her to stop being so picky
on some foods
seeing what she likes she gets to see
the ingredients that go in things
so i really like it i really enjoy
learning and the classes are easy you
got to check it out there's
anything you want to learn go on
skillshare you'll learn it all right
practice makes progress
advancing towards a goal is achievable
with short lessons and hands-on projects
there's nothing better
than getting better accomplishing growth
is extremely satisfying so do something
today
you couldn't do yesterday with classes
designed for real life
skillshare is also incredibly affordable
especially when compared to pricey
in-person
classes and workshops i wanted to take a
an in-person before the pandemic
uh cooking class with stella just for
the same reason
boom i'm not doing that even when life
goes back to normal i'm staying with
skillshare an annual subscription is
less than 10 bucks a month all right
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
honeydew and you'll get a free trial of
premium membership that's skillshare.com
honeydew our next sponsor is raycon
whether it's for work or play a lot of
us are going to be on the move again
this summer
all right i'm going traveling i'm going
to baltimore
i plan on going visiting family i plan
on doing a lot of getting out there now
especially that i'm vaccinated all right
uh and i wear my raycons everywhere i
just was down in mexico took my raycons
i'm out by the pool with my raycons in
mexico
listen to what i want to listen to
they're fantastic
people keep asking me how do they stay
in they have adjustable earbuds
you put them right in i'm telling you
raycons are great i use them
my stepson took them won't even give
them back my other pair i had to get
another pair so whether you're
working out a pair of raycon wireless
earbuds in your ears can make all the
difference you get
crisp powerful beats at half the price
of other premium audio brands
raycons look great they feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors
and with customizable gel tips included
for a comfortable in-ear fit and they
have multiple sizes they will fit your
ears for sure
and raycons are built to go wherever you
go they have quick and seamless
bluetooth pairing
24-hour battery life and a compact
charging case
i'm telling you i take them everywhere
with me on walks
to traveling i give them to the kids in
the car
so listen up raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to byracon.com honeydew
there you'll get 15 off your entire
raycon order
and it's such a good deal you want to
grab a pair and a spare that's 15
off at byraycon.com honeydew by raycon
dot slash honeydew now
let's get back to the do so uh
a year later i'm
sitting in the same gym friday
before christmas break
uh last day of work
the finished up my workout
sitting on the bench the cell phone
rings
pick it up hey this is the sheriff for
deschutes county
your stepfather's passed away we know
that you're not the biological son but
what we understand is you're the one in
the family that takes care of things
you need to come over here and do that
and uh and it's the same like
time everything [ __ ] date i'm how
many years later one year just one
one year not the same exact day but the
same
the same like in my world the same thing
it's friday
right before like all i'm sitting in the
same spot
same bench just finished my workout
[ __ ] right there and
i got the [ __ ] out of that locker room
so so uh
was the last time i uh yeah i quit that
job and decided i was going to take a
year off actually right after that
but so i drive over my sisters actually
end up they stepped up and took care of
everything
um which is interesting by the way i
raised my three sisters
uh even we'll talk so
they they're like brother you've been
taking care of us we got this
and so they took uh they took care of
everything
but this is what struck home for me
and this has had a huge effect on my
life
they left with nothing
the only people that they had my
stepfather had his daughters
they were the world to him my father had
me
it was the same it was everything that's
the only thing he had
and i've told some stories that may
paint them in a bad light but there's
lots of positive things as well and
you've got to look at those things
and but the only thing that they left
still
was just mixed emotion a mixed bag of
like wow i don't
know there's so much positive and
negative and all this
um i
no mark on the world other than that and
that mark was
a mixed a mixed bag
and uh that resonated with you it
resonated with me
why you didn't want to be like i didn't
want to be like that
i wanna
i knew i wanted to leave this world a
better place and i wanted the people
that i've been around and touched in my
life
to know i was [ __ ] there that's all i
say
all the time all you have to do is be
there
that's it show genuine interest and just
be there
none of the other [ __ ] matter you guys
you're living in tree forts for christ's
sake
you're living in [ __ ] tree forts you
got other kids with these palatial
mansions and
they're crying because they don't get to
drive [ __ ] you know
six-figure suvs and [ __ ] like come
on man
all you really need is i get frustrated
sometimes
people talk about you know being poor
and it's like look around
you've got the the gaming center you got
your fancy phone you got nice clothes
like you're not [ __ ] poor i'm sorry
um you're not you're not yeah you're not
and
i'm like it may be a struggle you may
have some challenge and anxiety i don't
wanna
i don't wanna you know but also at the
same time
be thankful for what you had because i
was thankful what i had when i grew up
and i can tell you all the lessons that
i learned about it
to make me a better person in this world
today so what i want to ask you is
after hearing all these stories growing
up in literally the
go ahead please let me tell you just two
more tidbits so this is funny story
well okay it's a it's a dark story but
what do you mean it's gonna be okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah compared to the light ones so
uh
it's uh thanksgiving this is high school
we actually had so in high school i
finally had a stable
like a mobile home that we lived in and
it didn't have it had running water had
electricity uh
the doors were curtains are using
kerosene heaters inside
we use kerosene heaters all the time um
no it was uh
it was electric heat so uh little the
little baseboard heaters
and they wouldn't keep up so like you'd
figure out the oven would be open you'd
fill the
bathtub with hot water so that the heat
would you'd be pulling the heat from the
water heater too
and but uh because the windows were
cranked closed but they wouldn't close
so you're covering them with plastic and
things like that
we had to do a two by four framed
kitchen to put a sink in
uh so we'd have a counter and stuff
because there was no there was no
kitchen in the place
but it was [ __ ] stable for four years
i was in high school
and and it worked great but we just
still
struggled so one thanksgiving it's
getting tight and uh
uh like maybe it was like eight weeks
before thanksgiving we'd end up getting
these pet rabbits because they were free
on the nickel ads
so pat runs over gets these pet rabbits
when we um each of my sisters gets one
i got a feeling one what i'm making a
man
and uh there might have been some
foreboding because they were named
breakfast lunch and so
they're my sisters like babies for like
six to eight weeks and thanksgiving
rolls around pack coats and he's like
chris we don't got a turkey this year
can't afford one
let's go out back it's thanksgiving
morning we go out there
twist the heads of the bunnies all three
all of them
is that how you do it i don't even know
how you kill around uh yeah hold it
between that
one of the ways that's the way pat
wasn't necessarily the best about some
things like this so
um i
i was just looking at my mom the other
day and she was like i was talking
i was talking about this like little
this lamb or the sheep we found and like
he
and my mom was like yeah i had to finish
that but he tried it with a baseball bat
or something anyway jesus christ
porcupine killing's an interesting thing
too because we we ate all sorts of [ __ ]
so you ate porcupine oh yeah
porky time we had all kinds of mushrooms
you got to skin it right away
but it's a little tough it's a red meat
uh but you got to get that hide off of
it right away but man they got a thick
thick skull
it's uh uh
that's how you do it because you could
shoot them with a 22 over and over again
and they still keep
moving them out of the tree
and you got to hit them and i mean
people are going to hate this podcast
they're like you're horrible
oh you're uh highlighting killing
animals like no do you understand we had
to
do the food we have to do this to live
yeah is that right that was
food that was food like that would
freaking hate
along with your target pick up a
puffball down from the stream and slice
it up and grill it you know like
anyway so we're sitting at the table
because it's all day my sister's been
just bawling balling
and uh they're sitting down and each of
them are eating breakfast lunch and
dinner
breakfast sister she looks at me she's
like
dinner tastes so good and she still has
the streaks through the dirt running
through her face from the earlier in the
day because they've been all there all
day
that's a pretty uh uh dark
that's story dark thanksgiving so i'll
just sum up the rest of my uh
younger uh ages so in uh two minutes so
i uh i went off to college by the way i
was valuable
amazing i was valedictorian i was a
state uh level athlete of high
school yeah and you're performing
athletically and
academically yeah like that from living
in a trailer at this point at least but
coming from the wilderness
and good for you and so i got a full red
academic scholarship to go to school
pursuing yeah an academic scholar
uh yeah uh pursued a double uh uh double
engineering degree
couldn't go back home i didn't talk to
him i didn't call home for a couple
about a year and a half because i gotta
ask you any anytime i call they'd ask
for money
first time you got your own apartment or
something yeah of course they asked for
money right
go to school and i'd give them money
because i was working full-time too so i
got a job i was working 30 to 40 hours a
week
uh in high school in i was working in
high school i was working
in high school too you were yeah uh
evenings and weekends
and then uh in college i worked
full-time
uh while doing the the dual engineering
degree but my first house when i was 21
years old
21. yeah what was it like to [ __ ] buy
a house going from where you come from
what is that's what i want to ask what
is that like
it was it was pretty cool and i needed
to because i was raising my sisters
so you took them well i took custody of
my three sisters you took
custody yeah oh wow okay i took how old
were they when you
took them in i didn't take them all at
once so they were i think
melissa was 13 when pat kicked her out
in the snow
um because uh bro uh well it's his
daughter right that's his daughter but
uh he thought she he she stole his
favorite cereal bowl
he's they're going a little crazy by
this point by the way he's going a
little crazy mom had left mom had left
him
she had a mental breakdown and she was
out in montana and so he had the girls
and he was not capable and was on a
decline and so yeah he kicked out
uh the youngest was living with a friend
and the second
was actually in juvie and the oldest who
was 13 at the time was living with him
and he kicked her out in the snow
because
he found it later on top of the
refrigerator but anyway
sorry about it so i took her first it
was right next to the lucky charms man i
didn't think the look
and then and i know
there's so much of that but they're
pretty [ __ ] funny like me and my
sisters get around we laugh about this
[ __ ] all the time
there's so many little ones that you can
that are just [ __ ] crazy like you're
just like
what the [ __ ] is this so
uh so i take custody of her i take cut a
city of janus the middle one when she
gets out of juv
and then uh when pat died um
there was a farce that she was saying my
youngest was living with pat
and so i had to take that's when i got
custody of her because she was she had a
good
kind of uh friend's parent she was
living with
and but she was gonna get taken by the
state so i got her at that time so end
up raising all of them
through their teenage years from 14 ish
uh through 19 or however long it was to
do where they were affording you the
financial freedom to do that for the for
you
well i lived in southern oregon in the
small it was a cheap place and so i only
had
uh the the two at the time so um
so i had two two there and then uh yeah
i was uh i was working on advanced my
career apparently
i was for some reason this kid that
didn't communicate well with people
was laughed at you whatever growing up
it wasn't socialized very well
i presented myself really authentically
in
the the world and like people connected
and
i didn't know why because i wasn't like
this
super extroverted articulate person
motivating or anything that i thought
like leaders were
um but i was doing really well and so uh
i picked up i was in southern oregon in
a small town portland's the big town in
uh
in uh in oregon so it's on the other
side of the state
and my the oldest sister by this time
was uh
18 19 and i said the house is yours and
i took the middle sister
and i moved to uh portland and started
working on my mba
and uh took a new job uh up there and
that's where i took custody of uh
the youngest uh as well so it was all
big steps so
um so then then i had led this whole
executive career doing company
turnarounds running automotive and
aerospace companies and
fixing them prepping them for sale like
from god
damn yeah fort aerospace yes
i know that's range man it is rain
[ __ ] range and that's and that's
that's right like i don't i don't like
to tell like my story
yeah there's some rough stuff but it was
just different it's different than most
people and i learned a lot and
from it but the thing that i have from
value is
i've had a huge scope of my life that
most people haven't seen
same time i also lifted a lot of weights
and did some other things in that world
too
so let me ask you this coming again from
your
upbringing what's the one thing that
you've done in your life with your money
that you never would have thought you'd
be doing
hmm i'm working on my pilot's license
right now
are you really yeah that's crazy yeah so
but
i don't know i don't really live uh i
really live
uh i gotta the only brand new vehicle i
bought was in 2005
i just like making stuff and doing stuff
and creating
so like i'm not a big
my house is nowhere near like what i ca
i i don't know
i can't say that
well it's obvious i say it all the time
my my trauma
your trauma it wouldn't have felt any
better any different
with this palatial mansion with this
like mental illness is mental illness
mental illness doesn't give a [ __ ] how
much money you have
mental illness doesn't give a [ __ ] if
you're you know a billionaire
if you're sick you're sick it doesn't
give a [ __ ] about class or
race or anything you know what is okay
the one thing
it cuz again i don't have a lot like i
don't have a mansion i don't have a
bunch of fancy cars i don't have that
that's not my thing that's also not
success that doesn't mean success but
what i do have
is i've got three different companies
i've got
the the largest one has over 50
employees and
it's a globally recognized brand and
we're doing things in the world to help
people live better quality of life to
get people out of pain
and it's crazy i work in this circle
i work with people that are the largest
known public figures
the biggest sports stars in the world
the best clinicians in the world the
best
i have this like network of people that
i work with it is so
crazy diverse it blows my mind when i
sit there and i look at who i
who i sit there and text message and
podcast like oh there's the best a
physical therapist in the world and
that's the best spine biomechanist in
the world and
that's arguably the best orthopedic
surgeon and oh i just uh i just dropped
an offer
and hopefully uh to oh yeah that was
dwayne johnson that just read my book
and oh the starting line for the la
lakers they have my equipment
at the lakers at their trainer's home
and at their personal home
um i like and and 90 plus percent of
all sports you know in professional
sports in north america
600 plus colleges any big name that you
can think of
uh all the the actors for the action
movie stars and stuff like that the sets
they're training on
you know they're using our equipment
like
that's [ __ ] cool that's awesome and
the better thing is
i get a message almost every day from
someone around the globe saying
you changed my life attitude yeah i was
in pain
it was messing with my my every aspect
of my life it was debilitating
i watched some of your videos which are
free put it in place
i went to the gym i just hit my old
squat max for a triple and i'm in zero
pain it's the clinician saying i used
your methods and i've got this 65 year
old grandmother
in 30 minutes i got her i want to learn
i had her crying because she knew that
she was going to be able to pick up her
grandchild that she couldn't pick up wow
it was the person that says i've read
your book three times i had to give it
to my mom
it is our go-to because of the impact
it's had on us understanding
how to live with stress and trauma and
and look forward in life and how much
you can accomplish
so that's [ __ ] cool that's amazing
it's amazing
and good for you so what was it in your
life that made you because we talked
before the show like
what makes you want to give back because
we talk some people
never even deal with the trauma some
people work on it forever like i'm sure
the people in your family have mental
illness tried and
maybe they've found another way to
relieve their stress what made you want
to turn around
and go hey i i want to help not only do
i did i want to help myself and my
sisters like which is
if that's all you ever did excuse me
that's amazing but what made you want to
help
every anyone out there well
mike my prior career you know i was
doing company turnarounds
to me my big thing that i just loved
that i cared about that i really enjoyed
in that
was the impact i was having because you
do that through changing people
through getting people to take on more
that they think that their personally
can accomplish and being able to
accomplish it and then the impact that
has and that's how you
create this cultural change on an
individual level and that was powerful
coach being a coach
being a mentor and helping people
understand that turning into challenge
turning into things that
scare you can lead to a better quality
of life same time i owned a gym
on the side and i was training to be uh
the strongest person in the world
and i was coaching people in the
evenings uh for free
that showed up to our jam anybody i'd
mentor them and the same thing like i'd
get more power out of
somebody hitting a personal record or
getting out of pain or doing
something than i did by setting a world
record
so you did set it oh yeah you did yeah
you were one point the strongest man in
the world i set the all-time
record for the squat on two occasions
ranked number one in the world for eight
years straight
and then over the last six years i
trained for something
very particular um i am the only person
still standing uh who has both squatted
a thousand pounds and
deadlifted a thousand pounds and done it
for reps nobody else in the world is
i did have both for three reps holy [ __ ]
so you squatted a thousand pounds three
times and i deadlifted a thousand pounds
for three times so they're specialists
there's people that have done one or the
other there's about
five or six people on either side that
have one or the other no one's close to
doing it this is what i read that
i've done both you're the only human i'm
the only one and uh i did uh the
deadlift was a sumo style it's
in the they only the records only count
for one rep but i just want to leave no
doubt in the tank that's why i did more
um it's still standing as the guinness
world record wow
so you man anyway but i love the other
part of it more
and i'm sitting there my kids are
getting a little older
i'm in my hot tub one morning and
kids are kids are waking up and i'm
thinking about you know how old they are
my son's about
well that's how old was this this is uh
he's 12 now yeah so he's about six years
old
and uh my second child she was
three years old and uh four
and yeah four six and four and
i'm thinking about them and i'm thinking
about them being in the situation i was
doing that [ __ ] too
and that's i started crying
and imagine looking at your six-year-old
and being like jesus christ when i was
six i'm [ __ ] getting
taken by the police handling you got a
nightmare you know like i didn't it
didn't strike me as
trauma exactly it was just life and then
if my kids started and that's when it
was like
it's like oh [ __ ] that's when the
emotions started coming
thank you that's when yes thank you
people don't realize that sometimes
you're living it you're just you're
dealing with it you are
it's later when you look back on you're
like oh my god i was this
i it was survivorman's job i was raising
even when i was younger i was taking
care of my sisters
raising my kids i had to be their
president even though i'm still dealing
with
guess what i've got the bipolar that
runs in my family my dad's side of the
family i got major [ __ ] issues there
it's
part of my life i had to make sure that
that wasn't present it didn't come to
the forefront when i'm raising my
sisters
i had to be there there was nowhere else
to [ __ ] go
and so it just never hit and then
watching my kids
i was that morning a hot tub and i'm
like i got to do something else i got to
do something more in the world i
happened at the time to also be
um doing clinical continuing education
uh that's why i know a lot of the
clinicia the times i was just talking
about because i
at the time i was getting asked to speak
at big events or at the physical therapy
or chiropractic colleges on the stuff
that i was putting in place in my
my own training the gym the stuff
because i was kind of known for
that stuff outside of my work
environment i was known as
this phenomenal athlete and coach and uh
i'm like i knew that i could
i could help people beyond just
the things that i was doing and i could
take that stuff that i was doing and
take it to a whole other level
and i had a great life
i had two homes i was building a third
i had a massive retirement i had a house
with a white picket fence
two kids a marriage that was entirely
comfortable
and i walked away from all of it
all of all of it the marriage the jobs
the house i was living in an apartment
had my kids half time and i was
launching
kabuki strength lost my entire
retirement
spent three years without a paycheck
running up every credit card i could
damn uh negotiating the the situation
with the
the ex-wife because um the kids was the
highest priority that was the
thing that kept me from doing that
earlier
um and uh and so
she's a great woman and uh we were able
to to do that very well we live five
minutes apart
kids are like it's it's as good as it
can get
not a bad words ever set in between uh
either and uh
and yeah that was
that was just a few years ago but i knew
what i wanted to do in the world and
where i wanted to go and i had a driving
passion to do it
driving passion to not just be lost to
the wind like pat and my dad
right to leave my freaking mark
well you've definitely done that and so
in five years i built a globally
recognized
brand i found an amazing woman found
what discovered what love is and passion
and
uh in the home have a third uh child and
the
three my two oldest are just freaking
phenomenal with the with the youngest
she's three years old now
and launched two other companies as well
wrote a best-selling book
working on my next book which is
actually focused on
on kind of business and self-improvement
specifically the first one's an
autobiography
and because i
resilience resilience of
body mind and soul are like you have to
have
all three and yeah my work is on the
physical side because that's i'm a
professional i know my
[ __ ] my team knows my their [ __ ] we're
the best
the best at what we do we make tools
that change the game
um but the other two can't be forgotten
and that's why i do things like this
that's why i write my
write my books that's why i that's why i
do this stuff because
we have to have all aspects of this
well we resilience it's freaking i i
use that in place of strength because
people think oh you just i
it's about squat and big wait no no it's
about developing
resilience so that when the things come
at you in life
you're ready for it you're ready for
whatever is going to buff it your way
that every opportunity of the things
life's going to hit
you and you can figure out how to you
can't change that you can't change the
trauma
you can't change the bad [ __ ] that's
happened to you and i don't want to
negate it
but you can use part of that if you know
how
to become a stronger version of yourself
yes story i've been telling a lot lately
is about
trees in the biodome
okay i try to set up a special
environment to separate it from the
world to see how well it does right and
to put trees in there they grow to a
certain height
and then they just fall over
no roots at all doesn't matter what type
of tree
gets to a certain height falls over they
finally figured out why
has no wind the wind
hits it and it says you got to be strong
you need to
spread these roots thick and strong in
the ground you got to take your bark
and make it robust to withstand the
weather and do all this resilience
so if you don't do that you grow and
kill yourself
fragile you kill yourself you're fragile
and so you have to have stress in your
life too much
yeah it can be a dangerous thing so it's
a balance but we do not live
the process of dying starts the
when we don't have anything to adapt to
trying to find
that easy life living in the mansion
with no worries or on the beach in the
caribbean
is death if you don't have some stress
and challenge some things that scare you
in life
to be able to turn into and chase
i love it dude we we were talking before
and i said you know you see
especially out here and this is men and
women putting all this money into their
hair
or their face or their lips or their
bodies or their
abs or their ass and won't spend a
[ __ ] dime
working on who they are it's all about
what i look like and they're the same
[ __ ] broken
[ __ ] up people that they always will
be because they'll never put the work in
on themselves so i
and they but here's the thing they've
had the trauma they've had it
their thing is if i look a certain way
i'll feel a different way
and that's the truth is you're you're
you need to turn back to the time that
made you feel that way made you feel
that you had to have those things
and talk to that person that's right you
do be that friend to that person
because i've been that person for me my
job is amazing
people ask me what my job is my job is
to be me
look i'm sitting here you know i'm
wearing my shorts
i dress up i might put on some
sweatpants my hair is a mess
you got that lol alzado freaking like
you know what i'm bipolar i'm adhd and
i'm just kind of all over like whatever
and this is the way i walk in the world
and that's okay
i got faults of plenty a lot of them and
that's
fine that's just fine yeah that is just
fine so let me ask you this
i got this video so people should check
out i got this video called
unkempt it's on my instagram check it
out
it's it's really really great but it's
basically talking about because people
have been harassed me for like a year
about my hair and i'm just like
this is me unkempt i'm also on a lot of
things
check it out it's a really good point
all right i ask
all my first guests um after everything
we've talked about now what advice you
would give to your 16 year old self and
i'm curious
what uh you would go back and tell 16
year old chris
oh man i mean at 16 you've already lived
three [ __ ] lifetimes
uh yeah i was i was
uh i was definitely an adult
at that point in time and
[Music]
that's part of the problem
i didn't have an opportunity to really
sit back
and figure out who i was for a long time
and this is a major struggle for me i
had different masks that i had to put on
kabuki sent me my company because my
nickname for a long time was kabuki
man to put on a mask people would see me
at work
and i'd be a completely different person
than
someone else that you might see
somewhere else
because i thought i had to be that way
and sure i performed well but that's
that's what i do i'm a performer
i'll get [ __ ] done and it took a toll on
me
and it nearly killed me trying to be
that
and learning to walk that way so it's
introspection and the ability to turn
into yourself
the ability to really find what your
north star
is your the way that you want to live
the
really the truly underlying values
not what society tells that you want to
be or anything that you can actually
ever
really have but the things that you can
move closer to
for me just to give some depth to this
this is stuff
like sense of family
or community it is
continual learning it is
challenge and accomplishment it is
having a creative outlet those are four
big ones
the creativity piece was one that i was
really missing in my prior career
but you should end up with like five or
seven of these freaking nugget pieces
that define
who you are people this is what i did i
tried to chase i need
i need degrees i need a career that the
money this and like
all these things that you try to figure
out how to build a solid life
but when you switch gears like i did at
almost 40 years old in
five years i was able to create an
amazing
life that every aspect of what i want to
do and the ability to spend
four to five more hours a day with my
family
by cleaning the [ __ ] and the fluff out
of it because i knew exactly what and
how i wanted to
to live and how i could pull the people
into my life that i wanted
that that had the same shared stuff
it's transformative what i've
accomplished
i was successful as [ __ ] in my former
career
but compared to what i am now
and what i'm able to do based on who i
want to be
it's a completely different game
and it's through that process of
of that inward turn to find
those nuggets to dig deeper to peel back
those layers
and that's what i drive people to do and
this is the process i kind of cover and
my
drive people to in my book cause i can't
tell you what what you want
you want the mansion and the fancy cars
that's fine no
no go why why why do you want those
why if it's a sense of
you know if it's because i know i want
to take care of and have
a security for my
and if i've got those things and i set
that as my you don't know why but that
could be the underlying thing
but if you don't know that you could
over leverage yourself
getting those things and get the exact
opposite of what you want in life
you could think man say that again over
leverage yourself and get the exact
opposite exact opposite because you said
you set your goals on the wrong
thing you said it on the wrong reason
that you didn't understand the
why right the why i want to be an nfl
player
and then one random saturday your knee
gets taken out and now your life dream
shot
why did you want to be an nfl player
there's probably
a couple dozen other ways that you can
realize the same things that you want in
life if you understand
why this isn't a sunday afternoon
project to try to figure out
this is an ongoing thing there'll always
be some revision
but once you've got that
then you can move past the setting the
the goals the bucket list all the other
stuff that people go
i need to check the list and figure out
what degree and what college i'm gonna
go to and what career i'm gonna get how
much salary i need to have and
when do i get married and when i need to
visit here and i need to have this
i hate [ __ ] bucket lists that's so
you have to know your north star
so you can properly figure out the ways
that you can
realize that that's great dude
please plug whatever you'd like again oh
i'm
i if people find value in stuff
read my book christopherduffin.com
christopher.com
christopherduffin.com or chrisduffin.com
there's a free audio download or if
you've got an audible you know whatever
uh links to it uh as well or you can
just find it on amazon sign copies or on
kabuki strength if anybody wants it
like i said body mind and soul so i'm a
big bleeder you half believer you have
to have the physical component
that's why i make the products the
education and have the coaching
services that we do at kabuki strength
we work with the best of the best
that's all that's and there's a reason
for that because
um yeah
and uh shoes foot mechanics is uh number
one global priority in the body number
two is a number one is
sorry foot mechanics number two number
one is uh ability to manage control
spinal biomechanics as well as back
breathing number one healthcare cost in
america
back pain not cancer not diabetes not
not heart disease
it's freaking crazy and guess what we
all control it
and two of the big things is uh
breathing and how we manage this
diaphragm to pelvic floor relationship
we can change that game so fast number
second one beyond that is
is foot mechanics and that's why i do
shoe designs and uh have a shoe company
so
that's great build fast formula people
are actually really into the performance
side of things
you can take the next step up with that
sort of stuff but number one you got to
eat right you got to train right so
that's the physical nature of stuff
but don't forget the other two thank you
so much for coming on
and sharing your story this has been
fantastic man
i and congratulations on all your
success
i mean man i got to get my ass he made
me feel like [ __ ] today bro
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all
next week
[Music]
you